[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOANNA SMITH: Hey everybody,
and welcome to Google+
Developers Live.
Come code with us.
I'm Joanna Smith, and
I'm a Google+
Developer Programs Engineer.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm Silvano
Luciani, and I'm also
a Developer Programs Engineer
for Google+.
And what we want to do today is
show you how easy it is to
integrate the Google+ Sign-In
in your application by doing
some live coding demo.
JOANNA SMITH: So we're very
excited to do that, but before
we begin, I want to mention once
again our Google+ Sign-In
boot camps that are happening
all around the globe.
Silvano and I are both very,
very stoked to be able to
participate in this, and we are
actually looking at nine
cities, five continents, five
weeks, 180 partners, 8 and 1/2
time zones, and I'm only going
to bring one pair of shoes.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Wow.
Google engineer truly
loves numbers, huh?
JOANNA SMITH: I think we do.
All right, let's go ahead
and get started.
So the first thing that we need
to do is create a project
on the Google API's console.
And many of you have already
seen our explicit instructions
for this, but we want to show
you, once again, how to do it.
And we're going to create
a Client ID for our web
application, and then we're
going to enable the Google+
API for our project.
Silvano, take it away.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So let's
navigate to the console, which
you can reach by
developers.google.com/console.
And when you are in the console,
you can see on the
top left, there is a selection
box where all your projects
are listed, and all
the actions that
you can do are listed.
And in this case, we want to
create a brand new project for
our demo, and let's
call it Demo GDL.
And this is a name that you
can use to remind what the
project is about.
After we've done this,
the console is
creating our project.
Our project is now ready, and
now we need to enable the
Google+ service.
So we just scroll the list down
to Google+ API, and then
we click on, and it's done.
When you will do this for the
first time, you will be shown
the terms of service
of the Google+ API.
Please read our terms of service
carefully before
enabling the service.
JOANNA SMITH: We are going
to hold you to them.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So now that
this is done, the last step is
create the Client ID, and that's
really, really easy.
Just go to API Access, see the
big blue button, Create an
OAuth 2.0 Client ID, click it.
At this point, we need
to input the branding
information.
So this is what your users will
see when they are shown
the content dialog by Google.
So please use a meaningful
name for your app, use a
product logo, which I'm not
doing now for the sake of the
demo, and also add the
homepage URL for your
application.
In the next page, we can
choose which type of
application the Client
ID is for.
Our demo is a web app, so
it's a web application.
And very important, your
site or hostname.
name.
This would be used to authorize
your website as an
authorized origin for
our JavaScripts.
So careful with the scheme,
which is important, and
careful with the hostname.
In the case of our demo, this
is localhost, and it's done.
Create Client ID, and
we are ready to go.
JOANNA SMITH: And at this point,
it's actually very,
very easy to go ahead and extend
your app to use other
Google services as well.
For example, to add the Google
Drive API to your project, all
you have to do is enable that
under the Services tab and,
later on, add the
correct scope.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Let
me show you.
It's faster.
JOANNA SMITH: All
right, go ahead.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So if you go to
Services, once again, let's
scroll to Drive SDK.
Let's click On, and we
are ready to go.
We can use Google Drive.
JOANNA SMITH: And so you see
it's really easy to get access
to all of our Google services.
All right, so let's go ahead
and start coding.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah, let's
see some code now.
As you can see, this
is a very basic
skeleton of our HTML page.
We will now fill in the empty
spaces using code snippets
from our documentation site.
And as you will see,
there's very little
that you need to do.
So let's go to our documentation
on the Google+
Sign-In, and you will find the
steps for the configuration
that we just showed you--
Create Client ID, Create
Client [INAUDIBLE].
And now the first thing that we
need to do in our code is
load our JavaScript.
So we can just copy
the snippet and
paste it in our source.
JOANNA SMITH: And you see, these
snippets actually are
littered throughout our entire
documentation, and we did that
intentionally to make it as easy
as possible for all of
our developers.
And of course, if you want more
details, you can always
check out our samples
to see more context
for how they're used.
But we'd love your feedback on
if these are helpful, or if
these need work.
Definitely let us know, because
we're trying to make
sure integration is simple
for all of you.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So let me make
this a bit more tidy.
And now, the second step.
We need to actually place
the button in the page.
And again, we have a snippet
ready to do this for you.
So let's copy it, let's
paste it in the
body of the HTML page.
As you can see, the snippet
comes preconfigured with some
of the parameters that
you will need.
There is only one change that
you need to do at this point,
and it's using your Client ID,
the one that we just created.
So let's go back to the API
console, let's go back to the
API Access Pane.
And now we can copy my Client
ID and paste it back in the
source code.
JOANNA SMITH: Now Silvano, since
we're pretty much ready
to go, can you take a moment
to explain what these other
attributes mean?
SILVANO LUCIANI:
Yes, of course.
So the class, which you can see
is g-signin, is the most
important one because using this
specific class, g-signin,
you're telling the library that
when the dom has finished
loading, all the elements with
this class should be rendered
as a Sign-In button.
The callback, as we will see in
a second, is what will be
called after the outflow
has been executed.
And that's where you decide, for
instance, if a login has
been successful and you take
actions as hiding the Sign-In
button, or if there have been
problems in the login, so for
instance, the user has clicked
Cancel instead of Accept, and
you can show them a message
saying, you will need to click
Accept if you want to do
more stuff with my app.
Client ID, we already saw it.
Cookie Policy, it's an
advanced parameter.
You can find a lot
of documentation
on it on our site.
For now, just stick with
single_host_origin for the
sake of this demo, and we will
probably do another GDL just
on this and other sign-in and
sign-out related topics.
JOANNA SMITH: Yes, definitely.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Request Visible
Actions, your app will
be able to write app activities
to the app activity
stream of your user, and this is
where you can specify which
types of app activities the
app will be able to write.
JOANNA SMITH: And we actually
have a selection of 10
different app activity types
right now, and they're all
based on schema.org.
But if you can't find one that
perfectly suits your needs,
let us know in the Issue
Tracker, and we'll definitely
be considering new app activity
types, just as we
were considering new moment
types during our Developer
Preview for History.
So just keep us informed.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And last, we
have this Code Parameter,
which in this case is just
asking for the authorization
for the plus.login scope.
But at this point, we can add
Drive here, for instance.
So I don't remember
the Drive scope.
Let me go to the Drive docs.
Drive, they have a lot of
different scopes to let you
have a fine grained control
on what the app can do.
We will just take the
umbrella one.
And if you want to specify more
scopes, you just need to
separate them with space and
add it to this parameter.
And we are almost set.
The only thing that is missing,
as we mentioned
before, is a callback so that we
can do something after the
authentication flow
has been executed.
Once again, in our docs, we have
a snippet ready for you.
JOANNA SMITH: This is a very
simple callback function.
You should definitely be
customizing and enhancing it
for your own app, but it's here
for you to get started.
And that's our goal right now,
is to help you get started on
your integration and see how
simple it really can be.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And it's just
a matter of seconds, so let's
go back to the app and copy
the callback in that.
As you can see, is not doing
much at this moment.
It's just checking that if we
have an access token, that
means that the user is
logged in, so we can
hide the Sign-In button.
And otherwise, an error has
happened, and for instance we
can log it to the console and
check what was wrong.
So now I can save it.
Last thing that I want to
do is let me add another
parameter, which is the
theme for the button.
And this is just because if I
specify a dark theme, the
button will be red, and even if
we have a white background,
it will be easier for
you to see it.
JOANNA SMITH: We do offer
several options for sizes of
buttons, as well as the theme,
the red versus a lighter
theme, and you can see all
of them in our Branding
Guidelines on our
documentation.
And you can also see information
about if you
wanted to make your own button,
which we're going to
show you how to do at the
end of the episode.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So now when I
load the demo, you can see our
big red Sign-In button.
And when I click over it, it's
opening the Consent dialog.
This is now opened in another
window because we are in full
screen, but if I wasn't in full
screen, it would be a
pop-up dialog.
An important thing here to
notice is in the first line,
it's telling the user that the
app wants to know a name,
basic info, a list
of people they're
connected to on Google+.
And this comes from the
plus.login scope.
The second line, because we
added the Google Drive scope,
is telling the user that the
app also wants to view and
manage the files and documents
in their Google Drive.
JOANNA SMITH: So this is
actually a good thing to note
because no matter how many
Google services your app needs
to use, your user only needs
to log in one time.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Correct.
And at this point, if we
click Accept, bam.
We're done, and we
are logged in.
Now, you can't see a lot
happening, because, as we saw
with the callback, it's just
hiding the Sign-In button
after a successful login.
We can try to do something
more in the callback.
So for instance, we can try to
get data on the profile of the
user and show it
on the screen.
So let me add to the body a pre
element where we will add
the profile info.
OK, there I am.
Sometimes I forget how
to use a computer.
And now, we can use the Google
API JavaScript Library, which
is bundled when we load the
JavaScript library to render
the Sign-In button.
So the first thing that we need
is to load the definition
of the Plus API in the client,
and we can do this in this
way, and then the callback that
will be called after the
library has been loaded.
At this point, we can
call on the client,
gapi.client.plus.people.get.
And we can specify as user ID,
we can use me because the user
is logged in, so this will
be resolved to the user
that is logged in.
And after we execute it, we
can add another callback,
which will be return the result,
which is the profile
info of the user connected.
And now, we can add this in the
pre element that we added
before to the page.
So let me find it by ID,
and this is a profile,
.innerHTML=, and now let's add
the stringified representation
of the JSON object, result, and
we can make it a little
bit prettier.
JOANNA SMITH: All right,
let's take a look.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So now if we
go back and we reload, I'm
signed in, so if you see the
button has appeared for a
while, then it's been hidden
after I was successfully
logged in, and now I can
see info from my
profile on the page.
This is a good time to tell
you a small best practice.
It would be better to hide the
button in the beginning, and
then when you check if the user
is logged in, you don't
do anything.
If they're not logged in, you
show the button to the user.
So in this way, you will avoid
this little effect
that we've just seen.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
the little flash.
So what you can see is we
have the button is fully
acclimated.
We've already got all that
working, and you already have
user info back about the
user that logged in.
But last week, we told you
guys about over the air
installs, and I want to stress
again how incredibly simple it
is to add these once you
have sign-in done.
And so at this point, to drive
downloads for your app, for
your Android app for your users,
all you have to do is
add a single line of code and
make one change to the
configuration of the API
console, and Silvano's going
to do that for you right now.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah, so let
me show the steps which are,
as Joanna said, really easy.
Let's go back to our project
in the API console.
In the same project that we
were using, we need to add
another Client ID, which will
be the Client ID of our
Android app.
So let's click Create
Another Client ID.
This time, it's not
a web application.
It's an installed application,
and we can
choose the Android type.
At this point, all we need to
add is the Package Name for
our app, which, for instance,
could be com.example.myapp,
and then we will need to add
the fingerprint certificate
for our application.
And you can find instructions
on how to generate the
certificate on our docs in the
Getting Started for Android,
and it's a very easy to
follow procedure.
JOANNA SMITH: It is.
And this is a good time to
mention that there are three
things to keep in mind when
doing over the air installs.
One is that you need to own the
app that you're going to
try to drive install support,
which is why you have to
generate the certificate.
And if it doesn't match, if the
fingerprint doesn't match
the original app, then you're
not going to be able to push
the over the air install.
And that's why we've already
had some questions online,
people trying to test over the
air installs with our sample
apps, and it's not going to
work for this reason.
The other thing to keep in
mind is, like Silvano
mentioned, if you don't have
both of these Client IDs for
installed and web applications
living in one project, they're
not going to match, and so
you're not going to be able to
drive the over the air
install that way.
So make sure that they live in
one API console project.
And finally, we do have quality
control because we are
Google, and we are Google+, and
we want to make sure that
we aren't crossing the
line toward anything
spammy for our users.
And so if you have a brand new
app, it might not work for
over the air installs
right away.
You do need to get some reviews
from your users and
some really good ratings before
we'll start pushing
that for you.
But just keep trying, get
your users started,
and it'll work fine.
I guarantee it.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And it's a
powerful way of getting your
app downloaded to a
lot of devices.
JOANNA SMITH: That's true.
SILVANO LUCIANI: There's only
one change that is needed in
the code of the Sign-In
button.
So back to the code, we
just need to add the
data-apackagename Parameter,
and you can do it here.
Let me see, package name.
And here, you will specify the
package of your Android app,
so for instance,
com.example.myapp, to follow
what I did before.
Now, we're going to
show this to you.
We have an already prepared
demo which is using an app
that we already have, and it's
already passing our--
JOANNA SMITH: Quality control.
SILVANO LUCIANI: --quality
threshold so that we can show
you how it's actually working.
JOANNA SMITH: And some of you
have already seen this app.
It's our PhotoHunt app.
We've been using this for demos
all across Google+ and
Google Developers Live.
And also, you can see all of
this code in its entirety
through our GitHub repository,
because we want you to be able
to see an end to end
implementation.
Let's take a look.
SILVANO LUCIANI: So
to our sample.
So I forgot to disconnect,
and this is why you
didn't see the OTA.
Let me do it.
So I can also show how to
disconnect applications.
You need to go to your Profile
page, About, and then if you
scroll at the end, you will
find the apps that are
connected to your profile.
In this case, it's PhotoHunt,
and what I want to do is
disconnect the application.
So I actually need to go to the
list of apps to do that.
And once I'm in the list, I can
now disconnect PhotoHunt.
And sorry for this,
but we are live.
JOANNA SMITH: Hold
on, Silvano.
Just wait one minute.
I need to make sure the tablet
is turned on before we try to
show off over the
air installs.
How are we looking,
[? Lewis? ?]
MALE SPEAKER: The tablet
is definitely on.
Little bit of screen flicker,
but it'll work for our demo.
JOANNA SMITH: All right, we're
just going to show you guys
the install, so it'll be fine.
SILVANO LUCIANI: OK, so now when
I reload the page, I can
see the Sign-In button.
When I click on the Sign-In
button, this is the new
Consent for PhotoHunt,
and it's similar
to what we saw before.
When I click Accept before,
because we have the Android
app, now Google Play is telling
me, hey, we have an
Android app.
Do you want to download it?
And it's showing me which
are my devices.
So in this case, it's
a Samsung Nexus 10.
If I had other devices,
it would show
me a list of devices.
And I finally can click Install
to have the app
downloaded to my Nexus 10.
Just see it.
JOANNA SMITH: Fair warning, it
is flickering, but you guys
can at least see the
install happen.
And look at that.
It's already here.
I didn't touch the tablet.
I didn't have to accept
anything,
because I own this tablet--
or Silvano owns the tablet,
and his account is
associated with it--
we have the app that
automatically appears on the
Home screen.
Whoops, shouldn't
have touched it.
We also have a notification
letting us know that PhotoHunt
has been successfully
installed.
And it's that simple to drive
downloads for your users with
your Android app.
All you have to do is add one
line of code and make one
configuration change, and it's
done when they log in for the
first time.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And I'm
a new PhotoHunt user.
JOANNA SMITH: Yes,
this is great.
So moving on, hey, Silvano?
The Google+ Sign-In button
is really cool, but in my
website, I like to fine tune
every single detail, and I
have very strict requirements.
Does that mean that I can't
use the button if I'm not
happy with the ones that
Google provides?
Said every developer ever.
So how do we respond?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Don't
worry, Joanna.
Don't worry, every
developer ever.
You can still have your own
markup, and you can still have
all the functionalities
of the Sign-In button.
I will show you how to do it.
There's several ways
of doing it.
I will now show you
the easiest one.
But first, let me disconnect
the demo so that--
JOANNA SMITH: We'll see
the button again.
SILVANO LUCIANI: We'll
see the button again.
Now, back to the code.
The easiest way of doing it is
inside this pane, where you
are applying the class g-signin,
you can add an image
or another span or a button,
where you will style your own
Sign-In button.
And this will be picked up
by our JavaScript and the
behavior will be attached
to that element.
So in this case, I can show
you a very simple thing.
I have a g+32.png.
I downloaded this from our
Branding Guidelines page,
where you can find a whole set
of icons that you can use for
your buttons, and most
importantly, you can find the
branding guidelines which you
will need to follow when
customizing the markup
for your button.
Now that this is done,
back to our demo.
I can reload it.
Let me reload the correct one.
JOANNA SMITH: Good catch.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And
now as you can see,
the icon has changed.
You will need to style
everything, so in this case,
if I hover over the button, it's
not changed to a hand,
it's still a cursor, but it's
very easy to do with CSS.
And you can see that
if I click, all the
functionalities are there.
And if I add an Android app and
a valid app package name
in the button, the OTA install
would pop up after
accepting the app.
JOANNA SMITH: It's easy quick,
just as we promised.
And if you want some examples
also of some custom buttons
that are already out there in
the world, you can check out
any of our launch partners,
which you can find as case
studies on our documentation,
to see what they did with
theirs, because a lot of them
did want a custom button.
It's very common.
And of course, you can find
details and explanations in
our documentation at
developers.google.com/plus.
If you have any questions,
please don't hesitate to raise
them in our Google+ Developers
community, because, like I
said, we hang out there, and we
love to answer questions.
And we're happy to provide
advice and let you know.
And if you aren't sure if you
meet the branding guidelines,
just ask us.
We're more than happy to help.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Or if, like
me, code is your thing and
you'd like to see more examples,
check out our
organization at GitHub,
github.com/organ
ization/google+.
We have the kick starts
for almost
every existing language--
Java, JavaScript, Python,
PHP, Go, Ruby, C Sharp.
And also, as I mentioned before,
we added PhotoHunt,
which is our end to end
sample application.
You can now find Java back end
and JavaScript front end
written in AngularJS and also
the two mobile clients,
Android and iOS, and we are
working very hard to add more
languages and more back ends.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, so we're
looking forward to all of that
and helping you guys out
as much as we can.
And of course, if you have an
issue in your own development,
you can raise a question on
Stack Overflow using the
Google+ tag, and we check that
daily, if not more often.
And finally, if you find an
actual bug in anything in the
APIs, in our Quick Starts, raise
it in our Issue Tracker.
Let us know.
And if you find a bug someone
else found, star that issue.
We use the stars to gauge how
many people are affected by a
particular bug, and also how
many people are wanting the
same feature request.
So let us know and tell us what
you think in our Issue
Tracker, and we definitely will
take a look at that and
use that moving forward.
SILVANO LUCIANI: And remember
that we are touring the world.
We are around the world in
different locations on
different dates, so check out
if any of the upcoming
locations and dates are suitable
for you and come code
with us, because we will be
really happy to code with you
and help you build awesome
integration
with Google+ Sign-In.
JOANNA SMITH: It's true, so
we'll see you in the next
hemisphere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]